c'est que les appels morini bosc le
faire gagner un scooter à isabelle est
ce que tu vas mieux
j'ai demandé à monsieur cisse algérie
pas que je vomis ce bon apparemment il a
l'habitude
monsieur escale visqueux de vomir les
adore ce mec je vous rappelle le
principe c'est très simple année dans un
camion c'est un camion bowling c'est à
dire qu'elle va devoir faire elle va
tourner sur elle-même
le camion appartiennent à tourner sur
lui-même et il va devoir faire un strike
avec des kits géante d'accord si le
strike effet mathieu qui est avec nos
téléphones retard est au scooter était à
terre
patrick donc savamment batik c'est bon
on est prêts on est prêts on est
contraire patrick juste excuse moi mais
ça nous fait deux jours avant de venir à
tanger malentendu avec le cadrage
n'avait pas tant d après que ça reste
satisfaite appelé patoche à benghazi
pour potash non merci mon patoche
attention prudent mon chéri parce que on
a on a encore besoin d'elle ouais je
comprends je comprends patrick d'un
professionnel ça fait 40 ans que je fais
des cascades à travers le monde et a
suffit d'une fois
allez on va de l'étape
moi je veux pas regarder quand j'ai peur
je voulais dire attention le dire au
revoir
elle est ce que tu as un dernier truc à
nous dire quelle paix demande si c'est
pas mieux pourvu que je m'en sorte pas
[Musique]
non pas toi à toi il a pas toi patois
isabelle est ce que je veux je te met
une petite musique pour te détendre
d'accord oui bien sûr est-ce que je peux
pas tous types à titre ou son site la
marche paraît aller 3-2 c'est parti
[Musique]
quintana
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
paris n'arrive pas envoyer en l'air si
rapidement
[Applaudissements]
la balle tu as du match chérie tu as vu
qu'il avait pas d'eau non c'est fait
attention attention je suis pas encore
sorti mais t'avais n'y avait pas de
match et rim pour l'instant non ban a
jeté lire ça et tu peux sortir n'y a pas
d'eau n'y a pas d'eau t'inquiète pas
c'est rien c'est un postillon merci
merci t'inquiète pas il n'est pas non
pas la plus dure encore isa oui ça n'en
fait pas venir c'est patricia weller tir
il faut qu'elle reste un peu là il a ma
chérie il a à sa barre issam al shihri
s'en va jalabert et la fsu fait c'est la
misère elle pas buteur n'est pas ton au
dessus
[Musique]
deux répétitions en est issu elle est
allée vous embrasser m'avait dit mais
venez venez mais faites attention aux
révolutionnaires à dos
m
a même un canari
mais c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
attention matin
[Rires]